ça devait être un vendredi paisible
comme les autres dans cette mosquée mais
ce 15 mars restera comme la journée la
plus meurtrière de l'histoire récente en
nouvelle zélande
la jeune femme en état de choc
agenouillé ici un homme prostré dans la
rue
les blessés se comptent par dizaines
dont un enfant de cinq ans dans un état
grave tout s'est déroulé en l'espace de
quelques minutes en milieu de journée au
coeur de christchurch la deuxième ville
du pays un homme entre dans cette
mosquée il fera ici 41 or i was here in
j'entendais des tirs les tirs aient
encore des tirs ça n'arrêtait pas
pendant 6 ou 7 me x et puis selon toute
vraisemblance le même homme prend la
direction d'une autre mosquée à 5 km de
là
sept autres personnes tomberont sous ses
balles une autre mort à l'hôpital sayyed
mazars ou dean était à la prière il
raconte comment un jeune homme a mis fin
au carnage
il s'est jeté sur lui et lui a pris son
arme il s'est enfui mais le héros n'a
pas réussi à trouver la gâchette
sur ces images on voit l'arrestation
d'un suspect l'une des trois personnes
qui sont détenues en ce moment mais seul
un homme a été accusé un australien de
28 ans qui se déclarent ouvertement
racistes et d'extrême droite
la nouvelle-zélande a été ciblé parce
que nous sommes un pays tranquille
depuis la première ministre peu après
des attentats
ces attentats qui ont fait plus de morts
en une journée qu'il n'y a de meurtre
sur une année
j'ai beaucoup voyagé je suis passé par
le canada je n'ai jamais trouvé un
endroit aussi paisible qui si avant la
comparution en cour du suspect la
première ministre a repris la parole
l'individu accusé de meurtre n'a pas
attiré l'attention des renseignements ni
en australie ni en nouvelle zélande
il avait cinq armes et je peux vous dire
que notre loi sera modifiée
le tireur a filmé l'attentât pendant 17
minutes
les autorités de nouvelle-zélande
avertissent que dix années en prison
attendent ceux qui partagent cette vidéo
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal